it's nine o'clock you're watching Sky
News since last month the Iranian women
have been taking to the streets to
protest against the death of 22 year old
Masa amini who died in custody after
being arrested for allegedly breaking
laws on wearing the hijab human rights
groups say more than 150 people have
been killed and thousands arrested
across the country nazanine zagari
Radcliffe a British Iranian National was
arrested in Iran in 2016. she was
detained for six years on spine charges
and spent months in solitary confinement
she was released just over six months
ago and returned to her husband and
daughter in the UK in an exclusive
interview tonight nazanine speaks to
Beth Rigby about how the demonstrations
in Iran bring back difficult memories of
her own detention she says the world
cannot turn a blind eye to what is
happening there a warning this interview
does include descriptions of torture
[Music]
that's me thanks so much for coming to
talk to us today look we've met before
but you do look a little bit different
today because your hair is shorter
you cut your hair in solidarity with the
women and men protesting in Iran and I
wanted to start with the symbolism of
this why has that gesture become so
important to women not just in Iran but
around the world
uh well you know that in September
mid-september massamini a 22 year old
woman was arrested because of what she
was wearing was not apparently suitable
and she was arrested by the morality
police and why she was in custody she
she died
initially the government
reported her death as a heart attack but
then as the story evolved it turned out
that she had brain injury and as she was
being she was resisting to be arrested
she was beaten up and as a result of the
brain damages she had she passed away
this was a trigger for the Iranian woman
to come out to the streets and in a
protest to defend their own rights that
they don't want to to be forced to wear
a compulsory building but also
even though that was just the main
trigger for the Iranian women to come
out that was not the whole reason so
Iranian women recently
together with the whole country they
have been struggling to make ends meet
there is poverty
there is a lot of repression in terms of
what is happening inside Iran and people
are
struggling to make ends meet so it was
basically
something which triggered a bigger issue
coming out talking about the rights
talking about what they
um what was taken away from them
um but I guess going back to your main
point I guess cutting hair is a symbol
of women
getting
more power about their body and their
hair which then again just just because
the morality police in Iran
is mainly focusing on the on their hijab
and the coverage of people and women in
particular it is a way of symbolizing
how
a woman would want to have the right to
whether cover the hair or not and I
think that was picked up by the
International media in a way and you
know internationally because women
across it's it's not it's not just about
the Middle East it's about I think it's
an international issue that women are
constantly uh
managed and
they are asked
how to wear what to wear and what to do
uh
and I think this is what people in Iran
have been really struggling recently but
I think people in the other countries
also resonate with that in many
different ways better your muscle
yeah
when you cut your hair
you said this for my mother for my
daughter for the fear of solitary
confinement for the women of my country
for freedom
are you scared for women in Iran
I do think women in Iran have been
sidelined
in recent years they were in Government
tried to
um
limits the role of women in Iran to
their homes only so women were more and
more becoming a symbol of reproduction
and they were asked to stay at home and
produce children and look after their
kids and this is not what women in Iran
would want
um and the reason I named some of my
friends in prison but also some of the
people who have been killed by the
Iranian regime as I was cutting my hair
was just to show
that even though I'm not with them but
my heart is still with them and it's
connected and of course my daughter has
been suffering alongside myself and I
was in prison
and I guess also with her it's taking
back control isn't it because it's like
hairs or long hair is often seen as
something of beauty and it's like it's
my hair I'll do with it what I will
exactly so it's my body my hair I want
to do whatever I want to do with it
um
you're here and you're seeing what's
happening in Iran and you are speaking
up
to see it feel helpless to you or you
think you can help affect change
um must be difficult it is it is very
difficult and of course
there are many of us who live outside
Iranian Exile and we would have loved to
be able to go back to Iran at such
circumstances but most of us can't
um but the story of what is happening in
Iran at the moment
resonates with my story in many
different levels but also in a way that
I was abducted at the airport I was in
Communicator for about a month nobody
knew where I was and this is exactly
what is happening to many women who are
protesting in the streets at the moment
they often get arrested put in an
unknown Place nobody knows where they
are
and I think
um
what happened to masamini showed the
brutality of the police force in Iran in
a way
but but then if he stepped back I just
want to mention that
um
uh the issue of hijab in Iran is not a
religious matter it is a political
matter that leads directly to the
sovereignty of the Iranian regime so
Iranian governments
has been systematically repressing
Iranian women and this whole system of
repression is the main tool they have
so we see that
if you stand up for your right in a run
if we talk about if you make a comment
one single comment about women rights
about forced hijab about Labor rights
you're automatically classified as a
threat to National National Security the
Iranian government does not turn a blind
eye on anyone who would have stand up to
the rights and criticize Iranian
government and I think the Iranian
government has been trying to
to link and tie its identity to force
and intimidation
we see that there are you know there are
so many in the in the recent years there
were so many uh protests and Uprising in
Iran as you might know uh in 2017 2019
and I think one of the main reasons that
we did not see any fundamental change
coming out of those uprisings is because
they ran in government heavily relies on
its repression system
um up until such time that they have the
power to do that they will stay so we
see
more and more
women talk about their stories of
arrests putting into prison solitary
confinement forced confession
we didn't used to be exposed to so much
information in the past
it seems to me you said you know your
experience
where you were effectively abducted and
then went through hell
and you were imprisoned from for six
years
and separated from your toddler which I
cannot even begin to imagine
um
so has it brought when you see this
happening to other women in Iran it must
number one
bring back your own personal memories
but it must make you really angry is it
is it a combination of those emotions
yes it does bring memories of when I was
arrested but also how helpless you are
when you are in custody
um
what
has helped the Iranian regime sustain
the way they are treating people is I'm
just the way they arrest you and they
disconnect you from the rest of the
world
so they put you in a solitary
confinement or they take you somewhere
unknown and they break you emotionally
so this
in my head
every time that I hear the news of
somebody being arrested I think about
what I have gone through the first
nights of my arrest
imagining what they would be going
through now
so the way it works is they just arrest
you take your somebody unknown
um they don't allow you to talk to your
family nobody knows where you are you're
completely cut off of the world so you
actually don't know if people are
worried about you or what is going on
outside Wherever You Are
and then we come to the point that
they break you emotionally
and they make you confess
something which is illegal because
according to the Constitution of Iran
you're not allowed to take any
information from people on the uh you
know torture but I think this is just
about it works
um and I think we hear more and more
stories of people who have gone through
forced confession Leslie just I mean you
were
put into solitary confinement for many
many weeks
and you talked about being broken
emotional how they break the regime
break people emotionally can you
explain a bit more if you're comfortable
about
what you mean by that what that
experience is I was in solitary
confinement for nine months
which compared to some other people is
actually nothing so
when I was in Evan when I was in the
general Ward you know we had anilofar
little farbayani who was one of the
conservationists she was one of the
eight people
who were arrested in 2018
under charges of spying for the Iranian
regime and
she had been to she had been in solitary
for 23 months
throughout which she had gone through
1200 hours of interrogation even talking
about it makes you think this is not
real
she when I met her she then told her
story about how
she was psychologically tortured so she
was asked to mimic sounds of animals she
was threatened to be injected air bubble
she was then shown a picture one of the
the eight people who were arrested was
subsequently
she he subsequently died when he was in
custody after two weeks of his arrests
Dr Cox said Mommy so they were showing
his a picture of his body to nilafar
saying that if you don't cooperate with
us
this is what's going to happen to you
and to your family
and then she also was threatened
to
um to be under sexually
assaulted and
she was having you know long hours of
interrogation throughout which she was
always living under this emotional
Terror that maybe towards the end of the
day they will actually do what they were
threatening me with and if you think
about any confession coming out of that
is there any value on that like if you
break people to the point
that they are emotionally tortured
anything coming out of that is not
valuable real it's not real
so we see many
fabricated stories and forced confession
coming out in the recent year in the
recent days but also there is one one
thing that I want to mention
because we hear more and more stories of
forced confession
um recently there is a transitional
shift in how the Iranian government is
using first confession previously
um
it was all about they would take away
any sign of torture on your face which
was in front of camera
to pretend that nothing is wrong
perfectly fine normal situation and
you're actually saying well you are you
believe in that whereas
in recent time
they do not make an effort to do that so
we have got this forced confession of
this lady who was arrested in summer
she turns up in front of camera with a
black eye
so the Iranian government clearly has
had a shift in terms of
it's not the fourth confession which is
important to them it's the message
through that and that is the warning
this is what is going to happen to you
if you disobey and I think that's a
that's a very important thing to talk
about that the
Emperor has no clothes anymore they
don't have any
um fear of telling the world that this
is what we do we put we torture people
put them in front of camera we ask them
what to say because this is the way we
survive
do you think they're doing that because
they're not worried about the
International Community and how they
might react or are they doing that also
because they have to take it up even
farther Notch to try and control
society that are getting really fed up
with it I think so I think it's both I
think it's both because like I said for
them to survive they have to up their
game yeah and that is to make sure they
show their power and this is the way
they do it
I guess
though for you
there's been dozens there's been dozens
of people reportedly murdered there's
been hundreds of arrests
so every single one of those to you in
your mind think what could be happening
to that person that's quite a that must
be quite a burden actually to carry
because it must bring a lot back it does
um but also
my story was a Happy Ending Story
I came out of it alive and what really
makes me upset is in some of the cases
that we see on a daily basis we have got
nakash like Army who was 16 and she was
a resident she was killed
and her family found her body I mean
they they brought their body back to the
family about 10 days after she was
disappeared so in many of the cases they
do not actually come back alive and I
think the world cannot turn a blind eye
this is just not acceptable and your
daughter I was reading that lovely lunch
you did with the Ft with with ruler my
old boss actually and um she you talk
about Gabriella being really proud to be
half Iranian that she sees it really
strongly as a part of her identity I was
going to ask you is that kind of also
what Spurs you on that you could be
forgiven in a way for wanting to just
completely turn your back
on Iran in terms of what you suffered
but you are completely engaged still
because it's part of you but also it's
it's for your daughter as well and for
everyone's daughters
yes but also I think
um it can never be
um
even though you might be far away from
your Homeland it is always your Homeland
yeah whatever you have been whatever the
way you have been treated it with when
you were in the country I can't
I cannot get away from it
but also I think my daughter is eight
but
um we see at the moment there is a new
wave of school girls rising up
and standing up for their rights to
take after scarf and to tear the
pictures of the supreme leader and to
protest and this is a new generational
shift this didn't
this hadn't happened before in the
history of of the modern history of Iran
well that's why I wanted to come and get
on to kind of why is it why is it
happening and I mean do you do you
presumably still in touch with women in
Iran what are they telling you about
what the mood there is and how is it
different to some of the protests that
you were talking about that have
happened in recent years
um yes I am in touch with many of them
um it's fair to say that
um
what is happening at the moment in Iran
has not been happening in the past
specifically with the school girls
coming out and I think that is a very
interesting thing to
um to remember and that is they have got
this courage that we at the rage didn't
have
it could well be because of their
understanding of the world it could be
well be because they're more mature but
also they have got access to Internet
and Media which we did not have so we
lived I was born at that time of
Revolution we lived um
with parents who lived through a failed
Revolution
our parents had
been participating in the previous
Revolution and it it was failed
but these gender this generation it
doesn't have that this generation these
girls could be my girls they could be my
daughters because had I been married
earlier kids earlier and they could have
been my kids they do not have that kind
of frustration of parents who have lived
through a failed Revolution and I think
that gives them a lot more courage
so we see that they are standing up for
the rights
with such dignity that we did not have
and I think that is fair to say that
they're a lot more Brave than than than
what we were
but Mars's death has really litter touch
paper hasn't it it was as you said it
was building up but it sort of it
somehow it's ignited this huge movement
but at the same time those those goals
those women you're talking about they're
being so brave because
protests can end up in a rest and death
do you have mixed feelings about
about the protest in terms of the danger
people are putting themselves into do
you just think they don't have a choice
I think it has reached a point that they
probably feel like they don't have a
choice and like I said it's not about
scarf anymore even though that was the
trigger
it's it's about
not being happy about the way they live
it's about frustration of daily life
it's about not being able to make ends
meet it's about poverty it's about
little things in life that is taken away
from them and even though it started off
with a scarf but I think it's fair to
say that it's now a more General kind of
demand that they are asking when they
they go to sleep but also I think there
is one one thing else that I wanted to
mention and that is
women in the street by their presence
they are creating an active Rebellion
so you see this video of this woman with
her head scarf falling down on her
shoulders sitting at the corner of the
street with her with her mask
not saying anything the God's passing by
and they look at each other
there is no communication but this is
just
her presence is so dignified and so
powerful
so women by coming to the streets are
making history
by their very existence and by just
being there it's just such a powerful
um kind of image that they're showing
it's not about
um
um violence it's about peaceful protest
but also it's about presenting
themselves to the world that we exist
see us we are here
and I think it's very powerful where
does it end I mean do you think that
there really is a movement in Iran that
can affect change because in a way these
women aren't just asking for
more rights they're kind of asking for
regime change right they've had enough
where does it I know it's probably an
impossible question to answer but where
do you think it could go from here
I was listening to
um
to a to a little short talk that one of
the previous members of parliament had
the interview she had and she mentioned
something really interesting she said
it's not about hijab anymore
but even if the government steps down
and backs off on the on the issue of
hijab
it's not that anymore it's
where people and how far people are
willing to go
and where people will stop so I think
people have moved on from the story of
hijab it's like an old story it's not
it's not hijab anymore because they are
confident that the government will
eventually back down on your job it's
how far The Government Can Survive
suppressing them and how far they can go
to achieve what they want so I think
it's a very important thing to remember
that women even though they came to
Street to ask for compulsory the rights
not to be forced to to wear hijab but
it's not about that anymore but
ultimately
I
think
the fundamental change will not happen
until such time that the government has
got the ability to suppress people and
until such time that that system is in
place
it will continue repressing women but
having said that
we see lots of
um kind of like I said their
generational change coming through and
their courage and the government is more
and more showing weakness so combining
these together I think it is quite
probable that there will be a change in
the future a regime change
or just a change in approach
but you think ultimately that in the end
the new generations of women will
prevail in this that they will
that this the ground swell is such that
status quo cannot stand what I what I do
believe in is that there is no return so
Iran will never be the same
um whatever happens in the future it
will never go back to where it was
before September but it could get worse
before it gets better that's true
and I suppose that's a bit right that's
a frightening thought isn't it in fact
that frightens me that's true
I've been surprised at how Brave the
women are because I have to say I watch
this from my very comfortable liberal
democracy where
you don't have to think about protest
and no one tells you what you can and
can't do
and I think they're really brave because
I think
I don't know if I would be that brave
are you surprised by How brave they are
um yes and no so I was surprised because
you can't not be but also I want
when I was in prison I was in Evin
um
often there would be like a very very
young women
coming to prison because of mainly about
hijab and they have taken off their
their scarf
and some of them were like 18 19. uh
and one of them was 19 and she was given
a sentence of 24 years more than her age
so I have seen many
a really strong
young women standing up for their rights
who were then imprisoned sadly they are
still in prison
um but yes it is it is a time that
you cannot not be surprised by and we we
talk about the strength of the women
though what just quickly just in terms
of The Wider community
um the supreme leader last week spoke
about protests they blamed he blamed
America and Israel
is there a danger of other countries
speaking out
um or do you think there's anything that
the UK could usefully do to try and help
the women or is it too diplomatically
difficult
what would you like to see happen
um
well I was a victim of
um
the fight between
to politics basically
and I have gone through that and I think
one of the things that really
my story was very complicated
just like many other stories
that bit aside
what really helped
my voice being heard was the media
so we are living in a world that is
inevitable that things get picked up
then broadcast then it's it's inevitable
that the cruelty of Iran what is
happening within the Iran they're in a
community not get publicized and that's
that one I think we owe that to the
social media so this is what didn't
exist 20 years ago and probably whatever
was happening at the time in a country
in a you know in a similar situation
would have been
um forgotten
we don't live in a world that things can
get so we've got cameras everywhere the
people have got phones they can just
um uh broadcast everything to to the
outside world so one of the things that
I think the International Community has
to focus on is the internet cut in Iran
so it's Iran internet because
they didn't want the Iranians to send
information out they also didn't want
the world to know what's happening in
Iran so
this cannot be forgotten this cannot be
forgiven so the the International
Community cannot turn a blind eye on
such a violation of Human Rights people
have got every right to talk about what
is happening to them and the whole point
about cutting internet is to get to
disconnect access to the outside world
so I think what the International
Community should do
we have seen many countries issuing
statements
and condemning what is happening in Iran
in my opinion that's not enough just
condemning is not enough
so we want them to watch
to act
to protect
um
when I was coming back from Iran two
days before my release I was made to
sign a forced confession
uh just to sign that I accept what I
have done was wrong yeah
I it took me six years to say I haven't
done anything wrong and I have been to
prison for five years under house arrest
for one year I was not going to sign
anything that was exactly the opposite
of what I had gone through I had
spent six years proving the opposite I
wasn't going to sign that
that happened
in the presence of Iranians and the
Brits that cannot be tolerated so if
if Britain in in this case France
Germany America
if they
turn a blind eye that is what is going
to happen they should protect citizens
it doesn't I think if they don't
that is what happens so the Iranian
government will have the authority to
force people but you you had to sign
that confession to get out didn't you I
did
in the front of British officials I did
which must have been must have made you
absolutely unfurious yes because I had
not signed that two days before
and I was clear that I'm not going to
sign it and in my head if a deal is made
the deal is made so
there is no way they do not send me home
because of a signature that's that was
my thinking but um
no that wasn't the case so
um
I was made to sign that paper and I was
told that if you don't sign it you will
not be put on that plane
after everything you went through to
have to do that to get home to your
daughter and to Richard is just
Ah that's hard
um Liz truss was there though wasn't she
when you were released she welcomed you
didn't choose them from secretary she is
now the Prime Minister you know her
personally I mean she helped
secure your release what's happening
Iran now is that something you feel you
could or should raise with her can you
actually have a direct line into her
well when we met when I came back
we talked about
um
um this shouldn't have happened
um six years after my arrest and it
should have happened earlier and then
she promised that she will be in touch
with the Canadian counterparts in terms
of uh putting an end to the Iranian
hostage-taking diplomacy so she did make
that promise so what I was expecting was
listruss to condemn what is happening in
Iran but I think what I what we saw was
a statement from the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs and not listro not the prime
minister
so you want her to actually be more
robust in this given what she has gone
through and she knows what is happening
in Iran she has just secured the release
of me and Anusha yeah so she is very
much aware of you know what is happening
in the country so yes I would have
expected it she hasn't
condemning uh what is happening in the
country in Iran and issuing a statement
is not enough
but it's a good gesture
but that is not enough in a way because
countries have got their own agenda so
they do businesses with Iran they have
got diplomatic relationships with Iran
so they probably put that a priority so
if they want to issue an a statement in
terms of condemning what is happening in
Iran they would take into account what
that how that would impact their own
relationship which I think is wrong
because human rights should not be under
the shadow of any other
um I get that so do you think also the
issue around nuclear proliferation in
Iran and those the deals are not working
very well and or economic relationships
that somehow
for say a prime minister they might put
issues around
security
above issues around human rights so they
don't want to agitate the regime so then
they don't speak out
I was yes exactly I was when I was in in
prison in Iran
um it was a couple of us that with every
single news about jcpoa and the nuclear
deal
the mood was going up and down
it's wrong
no human being's life should be attached
to an international agreement
if we talk about human rights we have to
act it's not just about
talking talk is cheap if you're talking
about we put
our citizens and the rights a priority
you have to really act just talking
about it doesn't solve my problem
I think no one's life should be attached
to any International agreement this is
exactly what happens to the jcpoa for a
very very long time they were talking
about we're discussing the nuclear deal
alongside of which we're talking about
human rights no that should be a
completely separate topic
and it should not be used as a leverage
to achieve other agreements and I think
that is something that has to be
improved because otherwise we will see
what is happening in Iran at the moment
so you would like the government to to
actually speak up more yes instead of
thinking politically this is not
convenient it's An Inconvenient Truth
that we don't want to look at okay
it's just come on to
adapting to freedom for you
um it's 206 days now since you came home
since you're released do you how is it
do you still feel you're in a period of
transition or are you always going to be
in a period of transition
um
sorry that I was just about to begin
that maybe I can think about relax and
um getting into the normal life
as
you know what could be a normal life
normal life is different to different
people but then again as an Iranian
woman as an Iranian in general you will
never be
um living a peaceful life there is
always something going on and I think
masamini was arrested and then
subsequently died on the day that was
exactly the sixth month of my freedom
and uh
with her arrest and her death and then
subsequent arrests and everything this
whole story of six years ago came back
to me again
I think it would be very hard to just
sit back and relax
um even though I am living far away but
I my heart is still with them in Iran
does it does it make you feel full again
for yourself it doesn't make me feel
um it seems as if I'm living in a
different world
um I have nightmares I have thoughts
during the day about
what my friends in prison do so that
does not Escape me when I was
um
in prison in November 2019 that was the
last time that there was another
Uprising in Iran which was
um
during which time the government
actually caught internet and I remember
during that time we had no access to
anything from the outside world we only
had access to the public State media and
a state newspaper so we didn't know what
was going on
so now being outside and my friends
inside yeah I kind of think about how
they would feel they don't know what is
happening inside
um inside Iran because they're in prison
but also at the time something
happened
which was a group of women in prison
went on a sit-in just to protest and to
show their solidarity for what is
happening in the country we only
realized what was actually happening in
in Iran and then it was not taken kindly
by the awards and by the prison prison
guards so they did a sit-in for about
eight days throughout which time the
phones were cut off the visits were
banned as a way of punishment and then
gradually all the people who were on
that sitting were relocated to different
cities in Exile different prisons and
cities in Exile and I think that is also
another way of showing
if you do want to do a sitting or
protest in prison this is what it's
going to we're going to make your life
even worse exactly I'm going to take
your rights away we're going to take
your visits away we're going to another
form of question you you talked about
that this happened on your sixth six
months you know had had you money had
the nightmares begun to go a bit had you
become a bit more restful in your mind
and then it brought it back up is that
what happened exactly that's horrible
I'm really sorry that's yeah so you just
managed to think okay I can maybe just
live again
yeah and then it's all coming back I
also read that lovely story about you
and Gabriella and you she went and got a
haircut and I mean you know like mum and
daughter haircuts is a completely normal
mum and daughter thing to do but for you
it was really special I was going to say
do you
even though this has happened for you in
life with Gabriella now does it feel
more normal
is it
um I do my best
to be normal with her but I guess it's
sometimes
inevitable children are very very clever
they pick up on our mood so easily
so she has picked up on my mood recently
knowing that mommy is not really happy
um
I've been trying not to watch the news
when she's around but I also try to
explain to her what is happening in Iran
so that she would know and I think she
would she will not be living a normal
life just like many other kids whose
parents are in prison or have been to
prison before that they will be exposed
to a different world that no more people
wouldn't but I think it would be good
for her to know that people in Iran
women in Iran are paying the price for
standing up for the rights and for
something that she as somebody who is
not going to live in Iran and she's
living in in London she does not have to
to pay that price and
um just to Value the freedom she has
but Natalie now the way you explain it
now that you were released you had that
transition Life the game as normal as it
can ever be once you've had a trauma as
you had
and now this has happened do you feel
now that until what is happening in Iran
is resolved that you will be bound to
that that will
as you said kind of be with you
um I do believe that prison has changed
my life
um it has changed the way I look at the
world
it has put my life in perspective
um
normal things doesn't
they don't bother me anymore I don't
care about little things my daughter is
very funny so we talk she likes shopping
so we talk about
um mommy doesn't like shopping and she
says while we used to like Shar Pei and
I keep telling her that yes but not
anymore so the things that it has
put my life in perspective that you
don't have tomorrow you only have today
um
this will be okay
okay
I'm
Natalie let's just talk a little bit if
you if we may about Evan
I've interviewed a new shape also who
was in heaven and actually despite it
being
an awful experience he talked a lot
about the camaraderie about the friends
he made you've spoken about as well
about the cooking classes and you talked
about how you did leather work and you
taught yoga and there was a gynecologist
and they helped women with women's
women's problems and they actually you
created this in the face of huge
adversity and and suffering this kind of
band of of Sisterhood where you and I
wanted to ask if you're still in touch
with people
um either in in prison or now they're
out presumably you form a community yes
my
some of them are sitting inside some of
them are out those inside I am in touch
with their families and I think they are
they are the closest people who can
understand what I have gone through and
one of the reasons that we
got a lot closer was because we had a
common pain we were experiencing
something which
um not many people would understand so
you will have many people in life they
have experience
things like you know losing a job and
financial crisis and with Kobe many
people experience death of their loved
ones but not many people have the
experience of prison and how you would
feel
having a loved one in prison and one of
the things that I um try to do when I
came out was to be in touch with
families of
white cell mates yes just to explain to
them what is life in prison so that they
would know that yeah basically they
shouldn't worry about their loved one
their loved ones in prison just because
their solidarity the community
it's like a normal life going on
except missing people the Injustice of
it being inside those aside they are
actually having their normal life they
can do things together they can read
together they can chat they can watch so
life goes on so it is like it it kind of
puts their mind at peace that they're
okay
and I think that would help them go
through that but you also you've done
more than that as well with them there's
other dual Nationals caught up in the
nightmare that you were caught up in and
one is more at tabas and Roxanne who
I've also interviewed
um his daughter appeared with you and
Richard when you did your fast press
conference and the whole of the world
wanted to see you I mean it must have
been I was there and I thought How brave
you were she'd just come out and
suddenly you had the world's median at
100 people wanting to question you
um
but you you you put Roxanne on the stage
to to to promote or to publicize uh
tabbers's case
um
do you agree with the new show as well
surely that the government who was also
who was released with you that the
government must do more to try and get
more adults as well
um I do and I think what was happening
to Murad at the time uh was
um unjust more actually been on the
plane with us coming back home
but he wasn't so
um it was devastating to his family and
I was very close to his wife Vida and um
and I think it was just not acceptable I
couldn't
be content with myself thinking that I
have come out and we left more out
behind
um and now we've got other dual
Nationals as well
and like I said everybody has got the
right to live and just being a political
Pawn between the you know the the
countries this should not happen to
people people should not be a victim of
that and just you
you you you feel like you will never be
able to go back to Iran or in the
current situation
do you think Gabriella could you imagine
Gabriella ever spending time in Iran or
would you never could you imagine a
future I guess where your daughter could
go and live in Iran or do you feel that
you couldn't have that that just doesn't
compute in your mind no I think we all
live but hope that we will go back yeah
yeah
and um
whether that will happen or not but we
just live with the hope but part of the
story of all of this is about Hope isn't
it yes
the adversity
the suffering the danger it's also about
Hope and I think we sometimes get that
somewhere in that
in those protests those women are doing
it because they want a better future
exactly for themselves and for their
children exactly which is actually a
positive thing even though the process
to get there is horrific painful I
wanted to ask you
just about a bit more about the UK and
how did listross manage to do what
foreign secretaries before hadn't and
get you out
um I don't know about what was happening
behind the scenes but I think what she
delivered was already built up for six
years yes and she was the one who
delivered it and
[Music]
um
like I said to Boris Johnson at the time
this
should have happened six years before
what outraged me was had I been told
that I was released on humanitarian
grounds
or because I was a mother or because I
was a woman or because they just wanted
to release me it would have made me feel
a lot better yeah than knowing that in
the end
the British government paid the debt yes
something they could have done six years
yeah and it was that was my life and my
daughter's life and yeah and that was
unacceptable I mean
and I'm sure viewers know this but it's
worth reiterating it your daughter was
two years old she was not even two she
was not into you were still breastfeed
you're still a breastfeeding mom
and you were separated and you could
only see her what once a week yeah
not to begin with I think to begin with
I saw her once every month for about
nine months all the time that I was in
solitary yeah and then once every week
that was been horrific
um just going back to um
those weekly visits then
um
I remember at the press conference
someone said were you aware of Boris
Johnson and what he had or hadn't said
when you were in prison and you said no
because I had an hour with the world or
an hour a week and that was time with my
daughter so when you're in there you
you were very isolated to what was going
on in the outside world was that what it
was like you didn't you didn't really
know what Richard was doing to try and
get you out you didn't really know what
the politics because you were this
because of Richard really you became
this kind of national story and you
weren't really you didn't really know
that I didn't know
um and the reason for that was in prison
there is very limited access to phone
especially in the women's Wards but also
the visits are very limited and very
short period of time quite often is
spent on family visits talking about
things and I had my child with me so I
would spend a lot of time with her and I
would often not talk about anything
except what she was doing and what color
and all and she would and I did not want
to expose her to the talking about
politics you wanted it to be like normal
mum daughter time exactly so there was
very little time we could talk about
what is actually happening outside
so most of the most award was happening
I only found that when I came out when
you've got came out
did it perhap it must have been you were
a mum you've gone with your daughter on
holiday you're a private citizen and you
come out and suddenly the whole world
wants to talk to you you've become
whether you wanted to or not
a famous person a symbol
you're a simple Freedom you're a symbol
of adversity how was it like how did it
was it was it a bit um
overwhelming or did you just think
whether I want it or not this is now
what I am this is what I Have Become
I think living in prison has taught me
to
I mean I don't know if it's fair to say
it has taught me but it has made me live
in this bubble that I only understand
what is happening around me in my own
way so my understanding and my feeling
when I came out was
there is hope
at the end and it will happen so for me
it was more like all those people who
are despairing in prison my friends
this is the end you will come out of it
just rise above it but also
um
I always say that
[Music]
it has made me a better person
given what I have gone through it was
tough it was difficult it was
complicated it was despairing it was
frustrating
and more than anything I was separated
from my child
um but then it made me realize that
um what is happening in Iran
was that so many people were suffering
because of
um you know the
the
misunderstandings the rights they were
they were taken away from them the
struggles they were going through
and that made me realize what they are
exposed to something I did not know
being outside and being outside the
country
so it made me more sensitive about
people's pain
and I think more than anything else even
for myself it was all those times that I
thought I'm never going to be released
there is release at the end of it and it
will come
and freedom will come
you don't have a choice in a way now
what you've been through when this
happens in Iran it's almost like you
don't have you don't have a choice
there's no option for you
but to speak up there's no option for
you but to cut your hair there's you
don't have an option you have to do this
this isn't a choice for you whether you
want to sit you know whether you want to
make a public statement or there's no
choice is that
I do think it's my responsibility
um especially because I know many of
those people in prison and
I find myself part of them I think I am
one of them but just pushed by force to
live in a different country and I feel
responsible
so if we end it like this then
um I actually got two more things to ask
you the one is
what is your message then
to the government to the foreign office
to list trust what's your message here
and now what would you want them to do
I want them to
observe what is happening not to turn a
blind eye
I want them to protect
and I want them to act
um
we cannot be indifferent about what is
happening in Iran
um and if we talk about protecting the
rights of our citizen we have to do
something about it
and I think we have to hold Iran
accountable and we have to
um
the world has to make it very very
expensive for Iran to violate human
rights so easily
it should be costly so you think they
should look at sanctions and sanctions
in place yeah
and would you would given that you
you'll experience and what you've gone
through do you think you could go and
seal his trust would you want to meet
her I mean you could maybe use
your experience and whether you like it
as I said you're a public you are now a
public symbol would you do that is that
something you might think about I
haven't planned no
no okay yeah I just want to ask you one
more thing
um and I think in a way you've partly
answered this in the interview but the
question I had wanted to ask you was
after everything you had gone through do
you now feel free
or did you feel free and now you feel
less free because of what's happening in
Iran
no I never felt free when I came out
and I think I've mentioned many times
that freedom will only be complete
if there is nobody in Iran put into
prison
for
standing up for their rights and
um
when my friends are out of prison
thought on the positive
you have hope and maybe even your hope
is turned into belief
it's not fair yeah
okay honestly it was an absolute
privilege thank you thank you for thank
you for talking to me
and Sky News has spoken to the
government about some of the things
nazneen zagari Ratcliffe said in that
interview a spokesperson said the UK
government has been very clear in
condemning the violence leveled against
peaceful protesters over the past three
weeks the foreign office also summoned
Iran's most senior Diplomat in the UK
this week to call on the Iranian
authorities to exercise restraint and
respect the right to Peaceful assembly
we have a tough set of sanctions in
place against Iran and are looking at
what further action we can take in the
short term in response to human rights
violations by the Iranian authorities